في السعوديه وسط هيئه الصحه العامه وقايه
بتجنب السفر الى غينيا الاستوائيه
وتنزانيا لحين السيطره على تفشي فيروس
ماربورك ونصحت وقايه المواطنين المتواجدين
هناك باتباع الاجراءات الوقائيه الصادره
من وزاره الصحه وهيئه الصحه العامه فضلا
عن اتباع التعليمات تعليمات السلطات
الصحيه المحليه واشارت الى ان هذه
الاجراءات جاءت اثراء اعلان السلطات
الصحيه في غينيا الاستوائيه رصد تفشي
فيروس
من جد ينضم الينا رئيس قسم الباثولوجيا
المناعيه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
الدكتور اشرف
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه فيروس جديد
دكتور فيروس مارب سؤال هنا عن هذا الفيروس
ما هو متى وكيف واين
ظهر وكيف ينتقل وهل هو بخطوره ما عاشه
العالم يعني في كورونا فيروس كورونا
مساء الخير استاذ خالد رمضان مبارك وتقبل
الله وساده المشاهدين حقيقه هذا الفيروس
انتشر منذ حوالي ستين عاما اذا سنه 1967
في الغرابه في المانيا مدينه فرانكفورت
حيث كان عندهم بعض القرده يعملون عليها
بحوثات الذي استوردوها من افريقيا ومن ثم
انتقل الفيروس من القرده الى العلماء
الالمان في تحديدا في مدينه ماربو ولهذا
يسمى بفيروس ماربو وهذا الفيروس ينتمي الى
فصيله ما نسميه الفيلو فيروسس فيروسات
الفيلو التي يتبع اليها ايضا بيروت او
ينتمي اليها فيروس الايبولا اي انه من
اخطر الفيروسات المعروفه لدينا حتى حيث ان
هذا الفيروس عندما يصيب الاشخاص
يعني العدوى تنتقل بصعوبه ولكن عندما يصيب
الاشخاص فان المرض يعني يكون شديد جدا
يبدا بالام شديد في منطقه خصوص المنطقه
الامعاء والمعده والام في الراس ايضا ومن
ثم تقيؤ شديد واسهال شديد والام شديده في
الجسم يتبعها تقريبا في اليوم العاشر من
حدوث الاعراض ميوعه حاده في الدم مما يؤدي
الى النزيف داخلي ومن ثم الموت في الكثير
من الحالات دكتور منظمه الصحه العالميه
قيمت مخاطره على مستوى المحلي في تنزانيا
مثلا بانه مرتفع لكن على المستوى العالمي
قالت بانه الخطر منخفض مع انه حتى معدل
الوفيات يعني يصل الى نسبه 90% في المناطق
المقتضه في باب السكان ووضعوا بعض الاعداد
يعني
لهذه الاصابات في بعض الدول هل يمكن
ان يحدث
الاخطر ربما ان يتحول الخطر الى المستوى
العالمي يعني تصبح هناك عدوى تنتقل على
مستوى العالم ويصبح الى مستوى متوسط او
مرتفع
قوي عن منظم الصحه العالميه بان هذا
الفيروس
ربما منطقه تنزيل تحديدا تكون منطقه قطر
عالميا ولكن دعني اسمح لي استاذ خالد ان
اؤكد للجمهور ان هذا الفيروس ليس مثل
فيروس الكورونا على سبيل المثال وانما
فيروس
يبقى في هذه المنطقه ولن يخرج منها نكاد
نجزم ذلك لانه لا ينتقل
مصاب بهذا المرض دكتور وصل الى اي منطقه
من مناطق العالميه الى السعوديه على سبيل
المثال هذه احتمالات النقل العدوى كيف
تكون خاصه انه يقال بانه وسائل انتشاره
اسهل مما كان مع الكورونا يعني ممكن يكون
من الاسطح ربما ملامسه بعض الاسطح التي
لمسها هذا الشخص سبب في اصابه الشخص بهذا
الفيروس
نعم هو نقول الاحتكاك المباشر او ايضا لمس
الاشياء التي يعني تحتوي على افرازات
الاشخاص مثل الملابس او يعني غطاء الاسره
هذا ربما يؤدي ايضا
العدو واذا شخص على سبيل الافتراضيه لم
تحصل حتى الان ان يخرج هذا الفيروس من
افريقيا منذ 60 عام منذ نشاته في المانيا
لاول مره وبعد بقي في افريقيا ولكن
انت تقول لاول مره فبالتالي احتمالات ان
يصل الى مناطق اخرى واحتمال وارد جدا
اليوم صحيح
نعم نعم حتى الان لا نعرف لماذا انتشر في
تنزيله هل
الخفافيش
غيرت يعني تصرفاته هل البشر غيروا
تصرفاتهم ام انهم كان موجود في تنزانيه
واول مره يقرون به هذه الاشياء تناقش
حاليا
جاء احد من تنزانيا مصاب بهذا المرض
احتمالات نقله لعدوى الاصابه في اي منطقه
يصل الى كم تصل
وباي شكل ممكن تنتشر هذه العدوى
نعم احتمال وارد استاذ خالد ولكن ضئيل جدا
ضئيل جدا ويجب الاحتكاك المباشر ولمس
الافرازات المعديه التي افرزها هذا الشخص
المصاب وعاده تكون الاعراض موجوده عنده
اين فتره الحضانه تقريبا من اثنين الى 20
يوما وبعدها تظهر الاعراض وان ظهرت
الاعراض يكون في ذروه العدوى فانه يكون
عنده اعراض معروف انه عنده المرض وبالرغم
من ذلك فقط في هذه الحالات يعني اصابه شخص
او لمسه شخص بطريقه مباشره ربما تنتقل
اليه العدو واذا انتقلت هذه العدوى لشخص
اخر من السهل السيطره على هذا الفيروس ليس
مثل الكرون من طريق العزل عن طريق عزل
الاشخاص بطريقه محكمه ومن ثم لا يستطيعون
نقل الفيروس عن طريق مثلا انا اشكرك شكر
جزيلا لهذه المعلومات الدكتور اشرف الداده
رئيس قسم الباثولوجيا المناعيه في مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي من جده شكرا لك دكتور